I'm moving things around in my place
trying new things so that's so the
backgrounds a little different it's
birds a lot of times my hair looks like
a bird's nest so these are the birds
that live in my head
hi guys my name is very public if you
don't know now you know your life is
different now
I used to comment on your comments all
the time and I haven't done so that much
recently so let's comment on comments
today guys come let's start over on
wheeler the place that once love for
one-liner Jemison now I'm afraid of for
real news reporting Illuminata new baby
every difficulty did you not know when
new person comments I'm one of my social
media platforms I graced the crap out of
them and welcome them to the it's great
family I used to hate people but why do
you mean when you can be dumb Illuminata
the more like a limit Akash today text
boobs dress it's a compliment it means
you are very you're a good source of
growth for a young thing you were rude
I'm rusty at this so give me a second I
ordered all three colors because my
indecisive nature is out of control
we're doorknob as Rehana would say no
not come on that's not weird
oh if you're watching this video right
now on the day that I've uploaded it
there's probably a couple hours left of
the aircraft hotdog t sale on represent
our concept interest seven I'll put a
link in the description bar below after
that they're gone forever until maybe I
bring them back in the future but that's
not going to happen so the distantly
gone but think it's 2075 think of 2007
more like bang ah 2007 that was me
giving you the score to a moment in 2007
when I saw a sheep get that by lightning
it's very traumatic yo Phoenicia thank
you for bringing that back up you look
good I thank for professional this
morning while wearing my grace helbig
hot dog pocket tea and I've never felt
more confident how I guess I'm so proud
of you good job Madison I mean look guys
like I said this up some pocket few
works wonders it's the kind of future
that says my eyes are right here be
pretty happy to practice I see four
happy more like don't tell me what to do
give Jesus [ __ ] I mean what sets I love
your optimism it's infectious like mono
super good obsessive grace helbig like
literally I only watched your videos for
the past two days dot dot dot well you
are definitely a new person and
congratulations welcome to this thank
you for watching on the videos if you
enjoy those maybe you'll like some of
the other stuff I do I have a podcast
called Matthew deke available in songs
on iTunes and on the fullscreen platform
also I've written two books great skies
RF join me grow up and great some stout
it are you pretending you have it you
can buy those books at your local
bookstores or on Amazon or you can
listen to them in an audiobook version
for free here's how we get the right
copy I don't want to say the wrong
things a lot of times they say the wrong
things and so I need to stop saying the
wrong thing you guys I don't work with
audible for years and I think they're an
amazing service they have audiobooks
they have news they have comedy and both
of my books that I have written are
available for download voiced by me on
audible and you guys can get a free 30
day trial and free first audiobook
download by going i really calm slash
great I'm really excited I'm going to
download Tony Robbins is a new book on I
went to a Tony Robbins event last year
and had a really wonderful experience
and he has a new book out and someone
excited to listen to that and you can
get your free first audiobook download
and free 30-day trial
oh my Wacom last grade they can
extraordinarily supportive being working
with me over the last couple years so
why don't you guys go be supportive back
at them I would appreciate it you are
appreciate it and no paper cut
no it's gonna quickly Ram that's a place
where I post photos kasi space you
persons are happy face more like a see
face a space your face looks like an ass
cuz it just fountain [ __ ] everyone likes
it it's very firm and very tight win
some lose some
you'll be great I would say it also hard
for you don't pull a muscle in your
happy face a cute
I see faith right and toys for the
summer but thank you
we're just coming back to Kelly more
like Mitchell Kelly and Michelle from
Debbie's house must live every day
feeling a little awkward about subject
areas their professional life
you can move if anyone else is as
obsessed greatest good as I am pretty
sure I just found it on Zara yeah a lot
of you guys I was great I was wearing at
South by doublet and I got it from Zara
and spoiler it's a skort it's got shorts
under it you have prank so hard you
pervert so my cooter is just flapping in
the wind no way shorts underneath of it
scores pranked it's also very
inexpensive and it's made decently still
highly recommend Gerald petronia back
for Joe mnemonic Jarrell krypton an
onion Gerald tripped on an onion Gerald
tripped on an onion because Gerald
gerald once Gerald still not bred for
survival here agrees those things you
made an 8 and a hot dog bun look good I
would eat it
Thank You general or you're very
descriptive and paginate comment left on
my Instagram about chick pea nurse I
made in my video last week I appreciate
your viewership and interaction with me
on social media Shila and if i dial a
more like Shila doesn't know how to only
deuce one letter at a time
don't tell her you've been great why
doesn't this that more common
I don't know Shila tell your friends the
[ __ ] comment on my stuff don't ask me
about it actually
dumbass friends not commenting on my
junk content thanks for being here
nobody quickly where we are right now
can't ever leave this place Mariana
Picasso and Braque and Picasso more like
Mariana pick a Zooey your favorite Zooey
what was your favorite Joey stuff or is
this the Zoey that used to be on that
PBS series doom remember that my little
brother was obsessed with her when we
were younger I should have known he was
gay
you were rude Heidi Klum was at the
Grammys she even sat on the lap of James
Corden sad
an emotional rollercoaster of a comment
wow I didn't think Heidi Klum was at the
Grammys it turns out she was and she sat
on James Corden's dad's lap okay well
she is keeping busy but songwriting cat
94 time the songwriting cat more likes
that's not true
that's not what you are you're not a cat
cat said at least to have an icon photo
because they're so full of them so I
mean I love all animals you've agreed
god bless these dumb unnecessary award
shows for giving great material this was
real stupid and wonderful thank you so
much I really appreciate their comment
and also yes thank you award shows for
giving me material the wels been running
dry these days so thanks for lubing it
up no Airbender electricity first man
for down under electric more like hair
fender Alexis your hair is offensive
thanks for 70 was super rude I saw
garlic once my people did a challenge
bad Derek Taylor more like staring here
name sounds like you're in the witness
protection program is everything okay I
just out you I'm sorry you've been rude
a little bit mainly in my life a little
bit of cocktails on my side a little bit
of braces what I need a little bit of
painters what I see a little bit of
Hannah in the Sun a little bit of
drunkenness on that loan a little bit of
Trinity Here I am a little bit of them
makes me up man Trinity number five that
is a beautiful beautiful song also what
a beautiful work of fiction to you'll
never see Hannah in the Sun just kidding
she sees the Sun way more than I do the
only thing I have experiences when I fly
too close to it at the end of a long
drunk regretful night okay let sit for
commenting your comments guys maybe I'll
make this a regular thing each week
because I forgot that I enjoy it and you
know what it feels good to feel good
turns out oiler
that's my self-help book one-page feels
good to feel good don't forget to
subscribe to this YouTube channel if you
haven't already and leave a comment down
below letting me know what I should be
reviewing other than award shows and
choose if I should be doing more
commenting on comments on a weekly basis
let me know
I don't know that's just general life
advice for anyone out there that doesn't
want to burn bridges or make enemies
it's just like never say the wrong
things okay here we go